quiero agradecerles por todo el gran
trabajo hoy eeuu está feliz recibiendo a
cinco nuevos miembros a la gran familia
estadounidense ahora ustedes son
conciudadanos de esta gran nación
felicitaciones
y siguieron las reglas o decirnos las
leyes aprendieron la historia y
respetaron los valores y probaron que
son hombres y mujeres de la mayor
integridad y no es algo tan fácil y
apreciamos que están aquí con nosotros
el día de hoy ustedes se han ganado
mayor
desde cualquier lugar del mundo se llama
la ciudadanía estadounidense no hay
mayor honor ni mayor privilegio y es un
honor para mí ser su presidente muchas
gracias
en este momento quisiera reconocer a los
cinco nuevos ciudadanos que se unen a
nosotros el día de hoy
de bolivia y ha sido un residente
permanente desde el 2013
con robert
en tres hermosos hijos en 2017 robert de
logros el sueño de comenzar su negocio
una presa de construcción que ahora
tiene cinco empleados él dice que ama
este país que quiere respetar la ley
eeuu me ha ayudado y me ha dado tanto en
la vida muchas gracias robert por tu
devoción gracias por la oportunidad de
ser un ciudadano gracias buena suerte
con esa compañía pronto tendrás cientos
de empleados querían este libro puede
ser la madre orgullosa de tres niños
habla inglés árabe y en francés y tiene
un diploma en psicología entonces tal
vez puedan entenderme ahora trabaja como
profesor en virginia y dicen me siento
muy afortunada de ser ciudadana del
mejor país del mundo un país que me ha
dado la oportunidad de la vida para
alcanzar mi potencial y mis sueños
felicitaciones
[Música]
muchas gracias
pero no es
es una es un gran éxito que nació en
india
que llegó a eeuu de 13 años de
desarrolladora de software ella y su
esposo tienen dos niños hermosos las
manzanas de tu vida
bueno presentaciones gran trabajo de
meta a buscar a buenos aires es de
ciudad y ese es un nombre muy hermoso y
ha sido un residente permanente desde el
es madre y tiene un pienso en nutrición
animal de la universidad de wyoming gran
estado
también es una veterinaria
ha trabajado como profesora sustituta
para la escuela pública desde 12 muchas
gracias y felicitaciones es un honor
estar aquí contigo gracias
y está buscando este día desde que llegó
a estados unidos desde ghana en 2015
habla cinco idiomas y trabaja en el
campo médico dice que la ciudadanía
estadounidense significa todo para mí en
mi vida no puede ser medido cuantificado
tengo la oportunidad de tener
oportunidad de trabajar duro y tener
éxito en la vida y saber que estoy en un
país tan seguro como eeuu eso realmente
es algo porque sé que me apoyen y muchas
gracias por esa situación es gran
trabajo felicitaciones a todos
con los derechos y libertades que ahora
ustedes disfrutan como ciudadanos no hay
sueño más allá de su alcance porque los
estadounidenses pueden hacer cualquier
cosa hoy también han aceptado los
deberes y responsabilidades que llegan
con la ciudadanía estadounidense y con
este juramento de ustedes han entrado
un compromiso inquebrantable con nuestro
país su juramento su lealtad con el
pueblo estadounidense con la
constitución y con la manera de vida de
eeuu con la historia y la herencia de
los eeuu ahora son de ustedes para que
lo preserven y lo pasen a la próxima
generación nuestra cultura nuestros
valores ahora son suyos para que los
respeten y vivan por ellos
lo que nos han dado a nosotros y lo que
nos ha dado dios y lo que está en la ley
de derechos en esta gran nación una
familia de todos los colores credos y
religiones unidos por los lazos del amor
saludando a una gran bandera
estadounidense presentaciones de nuevo
que dios los bendiga y que dios bendiga
nuestro gran país estados unidos
[Aplausos]